حان وقت الرد تقول وزاره الدفاع التركيه
بعد الاعلان عن شنغهارات جويه على مناطق
شمال سوريا والعراق
المخلب السيف والاسم الذي اختارته انقر
للعمليه العسكريه وبالرده تقصد استهداف
الجماعات الكرديه بزعم مسؤوليتها عن تفجير
اسطنبول الاسبوع الماضي
يرد الاكراد على الاتهام بالمسؤوليه عن
تفجير اسطنبول
القائد العام لقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
الذي قدم التعازي اثر الحادثه يستنكر
القصف التركي قائلا عبر تويتر انه ليس
لصالح اي طرف
نفي لا يقنع تركيا
طائراتها الحربيه
في العراق
شمال سوريا
خمسون الفقره
الكهرباء خمس مرات لقد دمرت بالكامل ولم
يبقى شيء
بقينا هنا لمحاوله انقاذ الجرح من تحت
الانقاض قبل ان تحلق فوقنا طائره فاضطرنا
للفرارا
مشاهد القصف التركي لمناطق الاكراد في
سوريا والعراق ليست بالجديده اذ نفذت
تركيا عمليات تغلب شمال العراق ضد وحدات
حمايه الشعب الكردي السوريه كما كشفت
الضربات التي تشنها بطائرات مسيره في
سوريا خلال الاشهر الماضيه ما اسفر عن
مخترع عدد من كبار مسؤولي قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه